SPEAKER: Data
plans aren't cheap.
And unfortunately, Wi-Fi
isn't everywhere yet.
But some apps get over-eager
when they open a network
connection, so we
decided to give users
a way to fight off apps that are
literally costing them money.
With API 24, we're expanding
on a previous feature that
allowed users to block
background network
access for a given app.
Now users can put
the entire device
into Data Saver mode, which
will restrict any background
activity on metered
internet connections
until the device
is safely on Wi-Fi.
Data Saver is easy to trigger,
so that users can turn it
on and off as they see fit.
And whereas users
previously only
had a blacklist of apps
that could no longer use
networked data in
the background,
now they can restrict
the entire device
and then whitelist the few
exceptions they wish to allow.
The effects of the
expanded Data Saver mode
are largely unchanged from
the previous background
restrictions feature.
These restrictions only
apply to background jobs,
since foreground services
are generally something
the user has requested.
And since this is all
about saving data,
these restrictions
only apply when
you're on a metered
connection, not when you're
on unmetered Wi-Fi.
But the other major
improvement for developers
is that we have created an API
to check whether your app is
currently restricted.
This allows you to build
better behaviors into your app
so that the user understands
what data is needed,
and how it will be used
when they ask your app
to do something while
it is restricted.
For example, let's say your app
wants to sync with your server.
Before, you would simply
kick off a background task
and hope for the best.
But now that you can check
whether your network access has
been restricted, your background
work patterns have shifted.
An obvious solution
is to identify
any network connections
you are making
that are not time-sensitive.
Your app should always
be data-conscious,
and these moments are
a great opportunity
to only sync when on Wi-Fi.
If you'd rather not
manage this on your own,
I recommend JobScheduler.
You can schedule your
sync to take place
as soon as Wi-Fi is
available, and you won't
have to worry about it again.
Now, if your use case
is time-sensitive,
or has some other need to do
work on a metered connection,
you'll want to check if Data
Saver is active for your app.
It's a pretty simple method--
getRestrictBackgroundStatus().
And the result will let you know
whether Data Saver is currently
on, whether it is on and
you've been whitelisted,
or whether apps have free
reign over network connections
or right now.
Checking that status might
look a little something
like this in your app.
If the only network available
is a metered network,
we need a switch
statement to determine
the best behavior for our app.
Although, again, if you
can afford to always wait
for Wi-Fi, you should
use JobScheduler
and avoid having to know
anything about the network
connection at all.
Check out the links
in the description
for how to set up a broadcast
receiver to listen for signals
for a Data Saver state
change, how to request
the user whitelist your
app, and how to test Data
Saver with the help of ADB.
Because there's
always so much more
to learn about being
data-conscious.
In general, though,
there are a number
of good and bad behaviors
your app may be doing
when it comes to network use.
The rule of thumb is to
respect that data is expensive,
and honor the user's
preferences when they
are trying to be conscientious.
It's their device, and your
app is a small part of it.
We want to empower users to
know what their device is doing,
and that means app
developers sometimes
need to work a bit harder.
But we've tried to
make it easy for you.
So now it's your turn to
make it easy for users
as you build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]